[Music]  Nintendo has revealed that we'll be able  to play the Legend of Zelda breath of  the wild on the switch at launch however  the game is going to take up a fair  chunk of your new console storage if you  download it I'm Matt and this GameSpot  news update is running out of space  downloading breath of the wild on the  switch requires thirteen point four  gigabytes of storage that means it'll  take up about 40% of the new consoles 32  gigabytes it's worth noting that some of  that storage may be dedicated to the  system's OS so the new Zelda could take  up even more than 40% of the available  space and if you want to expand the  consoles memory you'll have to do so  with a microSDXC card the Nintendo  switch and breath of the wild launched  on March 3rd as for the Wii U version  you'll only have to download 13  gigabytes if you buy it digitally for  more news about the switch and the  Legend of Zelda stay tuned to gain spot